the power of god is manifested in the beating
of the heart in the action of the lungs and in
the living currents that circulate through
the thousand different channels of the body
we are indebted to him for every moment of
existence and for all the comforts of life
the powers and abilities that elevate man
above the lower creation are the endowment
of the creator he loads us with his benefits
we are indebted to him for the food we eat
the water we drink the clothes we wear the air
we breathe without his special providence the
air will be filled with pestilence and poison
he is a bountiful benefactor and preserver
the sun which shines upon the earth and glorifies
all nature the weird solemn radiance of the moon
the glories of the firmament spangled with
brilliant stars the showers that refresh the
land and cause vegetation to flourish the
precious things of nature in all the very
richness the lofty trees the shrubs and plants
the waving grain the blue sky the green earth the
changes of day and night the renewing seasons all
speak to man of his creator's love he has linked
us to himself by all these tokens in heaven and
in earth he watches over us with more tenderness
than does a mother over an afflicted child
like as a father pitieth his children
so the lord pity of them that fear him counsels
on stewardship page 17 paragraphs 1 to 4.
you